for now and i'll just have you start out
with your
for the record for uh first and last
name spelling uh in your title please
sure my name is jordan somaggio
j-o-r-d-a-n-s-o-m-m-a-g-g-i-o
and i'm the youth development director
for the ymca of southern nevada
okay and i saw online that the
centennial hills ymca is doing a team
program um the next one is coming up
this saturday tell me a little bit about
that program and uh what the purpose of
it is
yeah absolutely so in 2017 the
centennial hills neighborhood
experienced a rise in a teen crime and
teen mischief and so
um organizations were coming to the y as
one of the leading providers of youth
development programming
in the nation to ask what services we
had in response to this local need
at the time we had our our teen summer
day camp program
and we had a few volunteer opportunities
but we realized that in this moment we
needed to expand and that's exactly what
we did
we first created a teen internship
program within the summer day camp
program
and so summer campers within the teen
group
could interview for apply for and become
an intern and shadow under some of our
executives and directors
and at the end of their uh six-week
journey
they were to pitch a program that the y
would consider
launching and over the course of the
next couple of years the teens pitched
several programs that we have
started like robotics and coding
programs and all sorts of really fun
things
but of course one of the things that
they really wanted to do was more teen
programs
during the school year and so we
launched over the last couple of years
uh
three uh new teen programs and then we
just launched another one
um late in the in the fall of 2020
so the three main school year team
programs now
are team talks teen connection and team
night
they occur on the first and third
saturday of every month
they are there's a nominal fee for our
members and there's financial assistance
for those
who need additional support they're back
to back so teens usually get here
around one and then they get picked up
around nine which is what they and
their families found ideal the teen
talks program is really
heavily geared towards youth mental
health which is especially important
right now in pandemic times
with rising rates of youth depression
and unfortunately youth
suicides so teen talks partners which
with bridge counseling associates one of
the
premier nonprofit mental health
organizations here
in southern nevada they send out staff
to lead
structured but open discussions on
topics that the teens
want to talk about so it's a safe space
for them to have productive
conversations on topics like
peer pressure and substance abuse and
yes even
depression and suicide then they move
into
the teen connection program right after
and teen connection is all about service
learning
and life skill development so the teens
engage in a wide range
of volunteerism projects within the
community be that
with the nevada animal shelters
with the cancer organizations
cancer groups be that a whole bunch of
different
projects after they combine those
service learning projects
with life skill development
opportunities so they get to learn from
those experiences out in the community
with animal shelters with cancer
organizations and then they mold them
into
lessons that they taught themselves to
inform future projects
and then they bring in outside parties
to teach them
more things so for example the teens a
couple years ago
said that they had they knew somebody
that was hearing impaired
up here and so they wanted to learn sign
language so we brought in somebody
and they spent one of their life skill
development days learning about sign
language
uh later on we have this session we have
somebody coming out
to teach them about money management and
financial literacy
and so they uh they get to to do all
these really cool life skills
development projects
um throughout the session then they go
into teen night which is all social
activity so we do things like
murder mystery nights disco nights all
sorts of these really fun
uh themed experiences where they get to
just kind of let loose
uh and and be kids have fun yeah
wow this sounds like such a
comprehensive
program it really touches on so many
factors of a teenager's life and what
they're concerned about and what they
think is important
um i really like that you guys bring in
the teenagers to talk about these
programs what they want how important is
it to collaborate
with the youth in our area
absolutely it's especially important
youth voice and youth choice are
especially important especially
in these adolescent ages teens have
a lot of complacent options today right
they can stay home and they can play
video games
and many of them lately have been forced
to do that
they can just stick to their
neighborhood or
when they're left unsupervised because
parents have to work and can't afford
child care
they're left to their own volition and
that's what caused the
rise in teen crime and mischief that i
talked about which launched these teen
programs
but to convince them to let go of these
other more complacent opportunities and
and
come to do something that's productive
something that develops
them into tomorrow's community leaders
requires that they are at the helm of
the decision-making process from
building the framework
all the way through execution and so
every component
of all of our team programs so i've
mentioned
three there are several others that we
have the
teens are at the helm from the very
beginning all the way through they pick
the topics for teen talks they pick
their service learning projects they
pick their life skill development
opportunities they pick their themes for
teen night
we have a program called the dreamer lab
in partnership with charlie rocket and
cox communications
at our heinrich facility in our durango
hills facility
those again are spaces where the teens
get to
decide how to create within them so they
come to these
very very unique spaces and there are
really qualified staff that will guide
them of course
but they're at the helm of what they end
up wanting to
grow into that's so great and
for centennial hills for in terms of
that you know crime that was going on
with
the teenagers there why is that is it
because there wasn't
many options for them to you know it's a
growing community they're adding more
things to do but it was it because there
wasn't as much for teenagers to do out
there did you guys ever discuss
that yeah absolutely it's it's simply
because of that that complacency factor
there's a a
common misconception that once my child
is
12 13 they can stay home alone
but unfortunately their brain isn't
fully developed they're still relying on
instinctual behaviors right they're not
thinking through
their decisions from from a to z and so
it's very easy to get into
mischief and then from mischief it's
very easy to get
into criminal behavior and that's
exactly what was happening the
the the wave was dubbed the caught on
camera crimes by teens wave
so it was teens going to houses and
stealing amazon packages
throwing rocks at windows um and and it
just evolved from that
so again it's it's this um something
that the y
is is constantly working on is promoting
the fact that the why is a hub
for youth and adults of all ages all
abilities and especially all income
levels
a common uh barrier to accessing
programs is that financial barrier but
as a non-profit we eliminate that
barrier we will work with whatever
income you have
to make sure we develop either you or
your child into the person
um that reaches their full potential wow
and for people that want to take part in
this for teenagers
um do they have to belong to the
centennial hills ymca how does that work
the cool thing about the y is we've got
four branches here in southern nevada
once you join
one you're a member of all of them so
there are lots of different programs at
all four of our centers
uh you join at one and you get access
to all of them a substantial amount of
them our free or nominal fee like the
teen programs
and then there are some that come with a
cost offset
so things like summer camp for example
comes with an additional cost
however of course what's extremely
important for
for the why is that no one will ever be
turned away due to the inability to pay
so you join based on your financial
circumstances and then you sign up for
the programs
uh based on your financial circumstances
we will take care of the rest
wow that's really great especially in
you know what's going on right now with
so many people losing
their work and things like that um is
there anything else that you want to add
about the program anything i didn't ask
about that's important for parents and
their teenagers to know
about the about what's going on with you
guys no i think i think
you've done a great job um touching base
on on some of these really important
programs
i'll say that um
teens initially want to stay home
and stay within their comfort zone but
something that we learn even as adults
is you can't grow within your comfort
zone
so i would encourage parents to take a
look at the why there's a lot of
different programs
within teams you've got six or seven
different offerings
by themselves find the one or two that
fits
what you are hoping to get out of the
experience and then allow the y to
support you
uh from the financial assistance aspect
if if you need that assistance
and then if you're in the community and
you'd like to participate in these
programs we're always looking
for donors and volunteers to support and
grow this work
jordan thank you so much this is great i
think a lot of our viewers are
really going to enjoy this information
so thank you